e9 oh you do realize that Jacob hasn't  been particularly nice to you in  previous schemes I think he built those  hotels there for a reason Amelie to  destroy you  that's 12 out of 13 don't go for the  heartburn he's going for the heartburn  oh the double whammy hey I'm sorry I  didn't know she was in surgery  hey guys maybe a snack  no I'm okay for now yeah I think we're  good right tiny  left it yellow Julian you got a spider  on your back deep left foot yellow  please okay reaction so what are you  talking about in the rules right here if  you land on a place and you don't want  to bite at the bank unless auction it  must action I'm the banker and I say we  auction and I'm gonna start the bidding  at ten monopoly dollars ten monopoly  dollars right you're hired from join  you're hired  going once twice sold to me it's  finalized oh I'm a freaking walking  dictionary folks you have no chance  what's that even need means I won Moo  jig and a little over for you for you